does apple's unified memory absolutely
destroy its windows competition well
today we will find out once and for all
with this ultimate multitasking ram
stress test both of these machines right
here have 16 gigs of memory but the
surface laptop studio also has a
dedicated rtx graphics card that's four
gigs of its own ram so it doesn't have
to share the system memory the the ddr4x
which is the latest speed with this
latest intel processor running on
windows 11 compared to 16 gigs on our
base 14 inch m1 pro macbook which has to
share that ram with its 14 core graphics
now we ran a bunch of benchmarks and did
a comparison here so we know our
baseline results and we are going to
start loading up different programs
background tasks apps uh browser tabs
and see does the windows keep up or is
the mac just absolutely gonna smoke it
so let's jump right in now right out of
the gate i'm going to restart both
machines to make sure there's nothing
extra running in the background nothing
going on other than what i want i love
that windows hello that just logs me in
without having to even put my hand on
there i let everything load up including
adobe creative cloud and let's see how
much ram is used it looks like our mac
is using 6.43 gigs just sitting here
with the background programs open
whereas the windows is only using 5.1
gigabytes so less with windows 11. next
i went ahead and opened five tabs in the
default browser safari and edge just to
load up some stuff into the ram and then
i loaded up another five tabs in chrome
which is what i usually use i have a
couple ign tabs here this one right here
has background video the auto plays
there's auto play ads i also have a
youtube video which i'll often have
running in the background for audio or
watching minimize so we have that
playing i also have our review of the m1
pro macbook pros loaded up here if you
guys have not seen that yet definitely
go ahead and check it out it's an
excellent review we've really tried to
do a great job on that and of course
google drive which this takes up a good
amount of ram because there's a ton of
stuff in my google drive we'll go ahead
and make sure everything is loaded up
and now look at that guys we have 7.6
gigs used 7.7 on the windows machine and
a massive
12.15 gigs used on the macbook that is a
lot more for the same exact applications
and browser tabs since these aren't
maxed out yet let's go ahead and open up
photoshop so it'll be one application in
the background and i'm gonna go ahead
and open up ten raw images that we're
gonna get loaded into photoshop
right away you guys saw how much faster
that was on the mac but that could just
be its performance in general now you
see both these are unplugged but the
thing i love about the surface studio is
the fact that it performs the same
unplugged as it does plugged in just
like the mac which is great and we're
going to be comparing the performance
compared to baseline not just between
the two zooming in so far into this
image
looks like we're not getting any
slowdowns yet when your ram is filled up
sometimes it'll be really slow and
jittery and laggy and now look at this
we just had the tables turn
the max memory barely went up at 12.7
gigs compared to the windows we're at
now 14 gigs 13.9 of memory usage so that
shot up a lot and now i'm launching
adobe lightroom classic and this is
definitely a memory hog we know it needs
a lot of ram so now that we have our ram
mostly full let's see if either of these
machines slow down out of the gate both
of these performed identical but look at
this guys
look at how much longer it takes the
surface to switch photos compared to the
m1 pro and the mac is pretty much
instant where the surface takes one to
two seconds each time we're switching
photos
that is pretty crazy because when we did
our hands-on both were identical but as
soon as we opened up those background
applications will you guys see the
difference for yourselves let's go ahead
and zoom in here all right that was fast
with both of the machines and how about
using the brush
all right pretty nice and smooth on the
mac just like it was before and on the
windows machine
all right you guys saw that lag that
they're beginning
and then it smoothed out now gotta be
honest i did not think we would get a
difference this early on in the video
whereas photo editing slowed down
dramatically on the windows machine
but now before we export these i want to
go ahead and open up our
monitoring software here
looks like all right so what basically
happens we got rid of some of the ram
now of the physical ram we went down
from 14 to 12.8 but it looks like we're
digging into the ssd now
when we're having to use some swap but
the same thing goes for the mac look at
that we're using seven gigs of swap now
and 14 gigs of physical memory but the
crazy thing is i didn't even feel the
swap on the mac because it didn't slow
down at all so now let's go ahead and
export these 50 edited raw images to
jpeg and we'll see if these machines
slow down compared to not having ram
filled up and by how much i'm very
excited to see these results export and
bam let's start our timer look at that
our memory use went up even more on both
of them our cpus are maxed out both on
the mac and on the windows computer the
surface is running at 4.3 gigahertz on
battery that is excellent and our mac is
almost done let's see if it's close to
the same performance as before and we
are done all right guys wow go ahead and
guess your thoughts down in the comment
section below and i will tell you guys
that the results are both machines
actually exported exactly as fast as
they did before which is very impressive
of course the mac did this much quicker
than the surface but the speed on the
surface was the same exact as having
only lightroom open so even though the
editing performance slowed down which is
actually where you spend the majority of
the time exporting has not slowed it
down yet so we're gonna go ahead and
push these machines a little bit further
and also look at things like video
editing which have to use graphics more
so and that might take a harder hit on
the unified memory that has to be shared
with the graphics instead of dedicated
now since we got into swap i want to
check if these systems slow down as far
as web browsing i'm going to go ahead
and open my first set of tabs so here
you go we're still open over here let's
jump back to say our first page here
okay did you guys see that
right away
the macbook instantly opened up this tab
whereas the windows laptop had to reload
that let's go ahead and jump to our
second tab
same thing there so it literally had to
get rid of that to maintain performance
in lightroom bam
once again okay wikipedia has to be easy
right oh looks like i got a search here
all right so here we didn't actually
have wikipedia open
that is interesting okay well what about
chrome um i always use chrome i know a
lot of you guys do
let's open this up here
we have our google drive that stayed
open on both so that is great it sucks
when you're right there so you have
something opened up and then it resets
let's go over to our document here
reloading on the windows laptop how
about our video here
all right that one is actually slightly
faster
on
the windows machine
halo infinite all right had to reload
quickly or pull from swap
and then once again this had to pull
from swap so for some reason youtube me
either maybe i clicked a little bit
earlier um but yeah it looks like this
either had to pull from swap now that is
interesting but
one thing that you guys mentioned you
guys wanted me to test is the
responsiveness when you're actually
exporting so i'm gonna go ahead we're
gonna run this export again and see how
responsive the system is first off let's
go ahead and launch photoshop let's
switch images
dang right there almost twice as fast on
the macbook
wow once again same thing
literally this one macbook's almost
instant
this thing takes a couple seconds to
switch
all right let's jump back into chrome
here
let's go to google drive
did this screen dim or what i don't know
i had auto brightness shut off let's go
over here not too bad taking longer to
load
it's a little bit choppy but of course
actually no both of these have 120 hertz
screens i guess my other question is is
it going to take way longer since we're
pulling all this stuff now on the
windows system than the mac overall
pretty good responsiveness from the
windows machine previously when we did
this test a while back windows 10 it
would really slow down if you're doing
something like exporting the photos now
the next thing that i want to test is
video editing with davinci resolve
because as you guys saw we're already
using over 10 gigs of swap on our 16
gigabyte mac i mean i don't blame it we
have 10 images and photoshop we have
lightroom we have those chrome tabs and
safari tabs and edge tabs with
background video google drive it's a lot
of stuff we have all this memory
pressure built up and since our mac has
to use that same 16 gigabytes of memory
for the graphics card as well it's not
going to slow down dramatically compared
to our previous tests when we just had
davinci resolve open whereas the surface
it has four gigs of extra dedicated
memory let's go ahead and start out by
just playing back this timeline
and look at that guys
the mac is playing back perfectly and
didn't even stutter at all whereas the
surface laptop it started out with some
frame drops even though it has dedicated
memory let's go ahead and pause
we'll play this back again we have a
couple luts applied we have film grain
applied and yeah every once in a while
we'll get a stutter loading up a new
clip that is interesting
let's see if we can play this back in
double time
okay not bad there's still some frame
drops you guys see that right there
even though we have the dedicated memory
and the rtx graphics card it's not
playing back perfectly now let's go
ahead and export this project we
actually have our previous results saves
right here 254 on the mac versus 426 for
the surface with that rtx graphics card
right out of the gate the surface is
going
fairly slow wow in our mac it seems like
it might be going slower i'm not sure
yet we'll wait for the results let's go
ahead and quickly just take a look at
our activity monitor wow we are almost
full of ram use we're using over 11 gigs
of swap here and our gpu is only running
at 55
so it does look like we might be getting
limited as far as graphics performance
because we might not have enough
memory but we shall see now right over
here on the windows machine
we're using a hundred percent of that
graphics card wow the rtx is maxed out
as there you guys can see our mac is
done which i know is gonna get done
earlier but look at this
it literally says we have
31
minutes remaining on the surface
how can that be
that is crazy our settings are identical
to before we're not at a battery uh and
it looks like our gpu is working at full
performance cpu is keeping up ram is
definitely full now i looked up how to
find swap on the windows system and i
got this thing right here where my this
is my full performance monitor
and look at this guys
it looks like i don't know if i'm
reading this right you guys let me know
are we literally using 39 gigabytes of
swap right now on the windows machine it
was lower but once we got in davinci
resolve it and started exporting it
bumped up
that is crazy where we're using 11 gigs
of swap on the mac now i'm not certain
about that but what i am certain about
is the fact that this thing is going
incredibly slow
so
with the amount of time remaining and
how long we've already been running this
export it looks like the surface is
going to take about 33 minutes or so to
do this export which is
crazy because before you guys saw that
it was just above four minutes and the
mac previously it took two minutes and
54 seconds and guess what even with all
this swap it still took two minutes and
54 seconds which is incredible it didn't
even slow down by one second and that is
with photoshop open lightroom open all
those tabs open we still have you know a
background video playing right here
let's go ahead and flip through this
stuff everything is still loading up
really really quick let's go back to
safari here
all right we got our different tesla
pages
look at that guys that is just crazy
let's open up lightroom there you guys
go
let's go ahead and flip through photos
no problem there let's open up photoshop
still look at that
we're literally just flying through
these photos here now i don't want to
wait another 27 minutes let me stop this
export here and i want to do the same
thing as that we just did with the mac
um let's go ahead and open up edge in
this case
let's flip through
watch this guys we're reloading these
wikipedia search is fine
let's go ahead and open up chrome
looks like some of this stuff is pulling
back from swap being slower
there you go so instead of having
instant response we are pulling from
that ssd now it's not as bad as it could
be but you guys saw that performance
time let's open up lightroom
right there we're slowing down
look how long it's taking to load one
photo
it went from instant
to two seconds and then that first one
was i don't know four seconds or so
definitely everything's kind of slowing
down and look at this guys look how slow
everything is just
trying to get through this timeline and
now guys let's do an ultimate test right
now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start this render once again in davinci
resolve which uses up video memory and
then we're going to jump into lightroom
i'm going to go and select all of these
photos this is going to be our torture
test we're doing a really cpu intensive
task as well as a really gpu intensive
task with video memory being used as
well as regular system memory let's see
how these things perform and how
responsive the systems are while we're
doing this and maxing out um the
graphics and the cpu so it looks like
right away
our windows machine is like locked up
with the menu bar is just sitting right
there whereas the mac each time i go
down we have full responsiveness let's
go and try to launch chrome on both of
these
bam
let's open up google drive
let's try to scroll let's open up our
youtube video
look at that right there instant on the
mac even though we have both photoshop
and davinci resolve running
slow down on the windows let's scroll
down here
ah everything's reset how about let's
jump to our other tab here oh no power
saver just kicked in on the windows all
right i plugged that in right away
that's crazy how fast the battery drains
on that sucker
we're rendering still and we're getting
just a little bit of slowdowns every
once in a while
oh did it clear that
did it clear that from the memory
as i scrolled down
it literally removed what was at the top
let's move to this tab oh what's going
on
what's going on
wow close google drive there too it had
to close it down oh wait
wow okay
the mac is done
with the export that was fast and the
windows machine is not even halfway
there
it should have been done by now uh based
on previous speed but it looks like it
slowed down by about oh at least at
least half the speed or more wow the
mac's done for the video expert as well
this time it did slow down when we were
doing both lightroom and davinci resolve
and messing with the system
but it only took one second longer than
before
where here uh i guess time wise it looks
like it's about the same
as far as a super long export very long
but wow while this windows machine is
going i want to get an accurate result
on our mac we're still in battery power
look at that we're at 70 battery
this one dipped
to 20 when we were doing the same tests
throughout this video that is crazy um
all right so let's go ahead and we're
gonna export the same thing i'm gonna
start davinci resolve we're gonna run
that again yep we're gonna re-render and
i'm gonna go back into lightroom i'm
going to export this one more time
because i want to get an accurate result
compared to how long lightroom took on
this surface laptop because we're
definitely seeing some crazy slowdowns
now
alright the surface is done at least
with lightroom for davinci we still have
another what is it 25 minutes or so no
but lightroom is finished and on the mac
we are exporting that video while at the
same time we are exporting
the lightroom photos as well and it
looks like they might get done at maybe
roughly the same time the surface is
blowing hot air all across the mac right
now actually right where the intake is
which is not a great thing but i don't
think it matters because look at this
performance guys
i honestly was not expecting the math to
do this good i thought at least in this
test with the video memory having to use
the same 16 gigs instead of have it
dedicated slow down
but bam oh my goodness davinci resolve
just finished lightroom finishes what
the same time same time right stop that
all right guys crazy resolve is still
running here it looks like we have
another what 20 minutes 20 and a half
minutes left for a video when we're here
it literally just does two exports of
each
this thing has still a while to go so it
looks like under this crazy load
when we have
14.6 gigs of swap running uh and we have
lightroom open and we have photoshop
open right here let's open up lightroom
look how quick it opened up right there
and we have our safari open and we have
our chrome open did anything close down
nothing closed down
look at that everything is still there
while that was happening
our video exported in two minutes and 56
seconds that is two seconds longer than
only having to resolve and nothing else
keep in mind that's also with lightroom
running in the background the whole time
as well exporting of the photos
and lightroom instead of taking one
minute and 44 seconds it took 2 minutes
and 17 seconds that only took 33 seconds
longer in lightroom and 2 seconds longer
davinci resolve when we literally ran
both at the same time they finished at
basically the same time as well with all
that stuff open in the background
meanwhile the surface instead of taking
four minutes and 26 seconds the video
exports taking about 32 minutes or so
still has a long way to go and obviously
lightroom is not running anymore so that
helps it out but
that was a huge slowdown and then the
lightroom at the same time instead of
taking two minutes and 50 seconds it
took five minutes and 23 seconds so
almost twice as long
instead of taking two seconds longer
and then of course it's still running
you guys saw the battery life
percentages as well we were looking at
70 percent compared to this one as a 20
i had to plug it in uh so that is a
crazy difference and then you guys saw
how much lightroom slowed down even
before opening up video editing
and all of the reloading of the tabs and
slowdowns on the system so there you
guys go i was thinking about you know
pushing these even harder
but i don't think i need to look at the
fans they're crazy they're like warming
my hands up
yeah the the truth is unified memory on
apple's m1 systems the m1 pro especially
then this is the base one of the bin cpu
the bin graphics 16 gigs
absolutely destroys
windows 11 with 16 gigs of memory plus a
dedicated graphics card that has its own
dedicated memory so when people say
that having the shared memory is a bad
thing with these macs and that's going
to slow down the systems and if you load
up the ram it's going to slow it down
incredibly that is simply untrue
this thing was stable you guess i saw
how fast everything loaded up how
responsive the system was how little
performance was lost when we were doing
all of that with tons of swap being used
we saw 12 gigs of swap use right now
14.45 gigs of swap everything is still
super quick super responsive and the
performance is almost the same even when
exporting photos and videos at the same
time which is insane i mean i knew it
was going to perform well i did think
this is where it was going to fall apart
but it didn't and on the windows side
after all of that we're still what like
two-thirds only done with this export it
is incredible
um yeah so if you're gonna want a system
and this is the price point that you
have we have two thousand dollars right
here for the mac 2 100
for this windows system and you can only
afford 16 gigs of ram
definitely mac is the way to go this
memory is extremely fast and mac os with
monterey works incredibly well with this
setup so there you guys go share this
video with the pc fanboys that say that
uh shared memory is horrible that slows
down that it's not the right way to go
obviously you guys see the real world
results so thank you guys for watching
help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it because about the 70 or so
of you guys are not subscribed you guys
can click above to help join the max
tech squad check out one of those great
videos over there check out our m1 pro
review that was an amazing video this
max and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]